so we're now uh heading to a place which
has
our batteries solar panels and uh
inverters
controllers so we're gonna buy all our
equipment to set up
our sooner system and it's about
one and a half hour drive
my key stuck
[Music]
thank you
so
so here we have our professional package
we have a pillow
solar panel mattress table crate
kitchen counter perfect
[Music]
for the batteries
but before we start we need to get two
other things
one is a generator and the other one
is wood
so we have the generator and next we're
going to get some wood
so here we have a big tool shop they
have some of this always useful for
spare parts
grinder discs to make some beautiful
sounds in nature
some electronic components and a lot of
parts for plumbing
and the cool thing is comes with our
packaging so you can just buy individual
pieces
and the same goes for all the screws
and the bolts
so that's cool
and the main reason to come is that i
need some wood
so now we're going to use a feature in
my van which i rarely rarely use i
almost wonder if it makes sense that i
did it
with moments like this i guess it makes
sense
this thing folds out
so originally i made this i could slide
in big
sheets from 244 by 122 because otherwise
they wouldn't fit
i rarely used it maybe three times but
i'm happy that i now can use it
so now the sheets are in
[Applause]
all right so we have all our components
now we have the panels which we're going
to build a frame
so we can mount them on top and on the
back of the container we're gonna build
a box that holds all the components
but we're gonna do the panels later
because first we're gonna start with the
box
and for that we have our route right
here which we got we have our generator
to power up
all our tools and inside the box we're
gonna
have our components here so this is
gonna be the case
uh to hold the batteries we have our
cables
here we have an inverter a
solar controller and a monitoring system
so all of the electronics will go more
in depth about that later
but that should be in the box and we
brought these things
back from the netherlands it's basically
holders for a big bag so you can store
things
and to keep things neat we recommend
using large bags or some other sort of
container to store your plastic
and i'm planning to make the box on top
of this so it's sort of a bit off the
ground on the back side of the container
but yeah let's just get started
[Music]
so this is actually my first time i
think in my life working with a
generator like this
so let's see
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all the cutting is done good timing
because it also starts to rain
so we're gonna pack it up and next we're
gonna put it all together
[Music]
so all the parts are ready now you can
fold them together
screw them and make it in the box
[Music]
box is now ready now we're going to
mount it to the container and at the end
we're going to add the door
and the roof to make sure everything is
then aligned
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so here we have the roof we need to go
on there
and we're going to add a bit of rubber
seal
we still had laying around it's a bit
hard but
should still be decent enough
to make sure it's waterproof
personally i wouldn't have bought this
if we didn't have it but it was in the
container anyway and it was slowly
drying up
so i figured let's just use it but i
don't think it's really necessary
all right so the box is now ready
case closed um but uh
today is also finished so tomorrow we're
gonna do the electronics
all right so now it's time to wire up
all the electronics and i've got my
schematics right here
and i'm going to get one big board which
i had as a leftover
where i mount on all the components so i
can quite easily install it in the box
with a few screws
and so i just wire it all up here
[Music]
so
[Music]
do all right
so let me show you the final electronic
box
right here also added some ventilation
in case it gets warm mainly to keep the
battery cool
not sure yet if it's enough in the
summer we might need active cooling but
we're gonna just monitor and see how it
behaves
um so here's our system
so let me briefly explain what's going
on so here the solar panels should
come in but we'll do that next week and
then they go here
to this fuse box from the fuse box they
go to the smart controller
and that kind of regulates and balances
out all the solar that comes in
to make sure it captures the peaks and
the down points and balances out a bit
[Music]
from here it goes through the battery
which is a lithium
battery 10 kilowatt which should be
enough to power
a small household so i guess that means
us
um but meanwhile also you have this
thing which is a monitoring system
which connects all these components
together and with this one you can
actually see
how much energy you use how much
kilowatts you get on a day what are the
peak moments the down moments
which time of the day you have the most
so this is actually very valuable to get
the most out of your system
and up until now everything is still
running on 48 volts
so the whole battery as well and that's
where this thing comes in
an inverter so this transforms 48 volts
to 230 volts which means after this one
you can actually just use it for your
normal appliances like a blender washing
machine and stuff like this
and here we have a few fusions that go
from the battery to
the 230 volts that's kind of briefly the
system
but it doesn't really work yet because
we still don't have solar panels
and that's actually what we're going to
do next week we have six solar panels
of 380 watts each which we're gonna
mount on the roof so we're gonna make a
frame
and connect these panels right here
and uh yeah we should actually get
started because we've seen
some cats walking on top of it and some
snails going over it
so nature is giving us a little bit of
pressure
so in next video uh yeah we're going to
hook everything up and you can see the
system running we also
take a look at this app that sort of
monitors everything so it should be
exciting
if you want to see make sure to
subscribe so you don't miss it
also take that little bell and if you
like what we do
make sure to visit
support.projectcomp.com
to see how you can help out thanks for
watching see you in the next video